-We're back
with Lin-Manuel Miranda.
And congratulations
on "Tick, Tick...Boom!"
It's receiving
fantastic reviews.
-Thank you.
-So this is based on
the writer of "Rent,"
but this is not about
this part of his career.
Or that part of his career,
I should say.
This was
about something earlier.
This was about a failure.
-Yeah, he --
Jonathan Larson was --
was an aspiring composer.
I can't relate at all.
[ Laughter ]
And he spent his 20s
trying to --
First of all, he tried to do
an adaptation of "1984."
Couldn't get the rights.
He said,
"I'll write my own dystopia."
He spent his 20s writing
this musical called "Superbia,"
and everyone basically said,
"It's really interesting.
You're very talented.
What else do you have?"
And he said,
"I spent my 20s writing this."
And I think he processed
that loss
and the fact that no one
wanted to produce it
by writing this one-man show,
called "Tick, Tick...Boom!"
And he performed it
as a rock monologue
with a band all over the Village
and all over New York.
And he, basically, was like --
it was him processing
spending his 20s on something
nobody wanted to see.
And, as a result,
it's a brilliant
sort of portrait
of this great artist
as a young man and figuring out
whether he wants to proceed
in this line of work or not.
And "Rent" is still
way down on the horizon.
-And you were how old
when you first see this?
-So, I was 17 when I saw "Rent."
I saw the original cast
for my 17th birthday
from the back row of
the Nederlander Theatre.
And that was the show that made
me want to write musicals.
It was the first, really,
contemporary musical I ever saw.
And then,
after Larson's passing,
it was commissioned to --
to be turned into
an off-Broadway show.
They basically turned it into a
three-person off Broadway show,
and I saw that.
Now I'm a senior theater major.
I'm like, "I'm a theater major.
It's just after September 11th."
Like, "What do I
have to offer the world?"
And I went and saw
this brilliant musical,
directed by Scott Schwartz,
starring Raul Esparza,
and it was basically
this sneak preview of my 20s.
It was this brilliant kind of
wrestling with,
"What are we meant
to be doing with our time?"
And it was even more specific
and brilliant to me
than my experiencing "Rent"
at 17.
And so, it's been sitting in me,
like, ever since.
And I was thrilled to get to
direct the film adaptation.
-You get it to direct it, and
you get to take this core story,
but, obviously, because
it's film, in some degrees,
you get to make it bigger,
and one way that you seem
to make it grander and sort of
a tribute to Jonathan
is all these Broadway cameos.
-Yeah.
-And -- And it sort of goes back
to what you were saying
about the speed of thought.
Right?
Like, you get to do -- you get
to internalize this person,
and it must have been so cool
to reach out to the Broadway
community and explain
why it's important
to do a cameo in this film.
-Sure.
And half of the folks
that people
are considering cameos,
they're not cameos to me.
They're just, like,
great New York actors
that I want to be --
You know,
you know this from this.
You've got Richard Kind
in every third thing.
-Absolutely.
-Richard Kind
is in our movie, too.
-You can't say no
to Richard Kind.
-You can't
say no to Richard Kind.
-And he will call you.
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
But, you know, it's -- it's --
I just wanted
great New York actors
to be in this great
New York story.
But there are elements to it
that, you know, Jonathan was --
never got to see his success.
You know, he passed away
the night before
"Rent's"
first public performance.
And the goal at every stage was,
"What would Jonathan Larson do?"
and "What would
Jonathan Larson want to see?"
And the film is an opportunity
to go to New York in 1990,
that sort of post-Koch,
pre-Giuliani weirdo time
in New York
that I remember as a child
and populated
with Jonathan's heroes.
I mean, that was sort of the
goal at every step of the way.
-One cameo
that I think people
were very excited to see
is your father.
-Oh, sure.
-Yeah.
-When you talk about
New York royalty...
-Yeah.
-...Luis Miranda Jr...
-When you get Luis,
I'm like, "Is that the Luis?"
-"They -- They booked Luis?"
[ Laughter ]
-No, but how is your dad
to work with as --
when you're the director?
-Ha!
[ Laughter ]
-He's -- It -- Well...
I could've made it
easier on myself,
because the scene he's in
is this uninterrupted --
It's, like,
my only Scorsese take.
It's this, like, long dance
sequence in a New York lobby,
and I also wanted it
to play like
they're moving in slow motion.
So all the dancers are dancing
at 1.75 speed.
So my dad has a really specific
cue, and it goes by really fast.
It's like,
♪ Hello to dear Mr. Doorman ♪
♪ Who looks like
Captain Kangaroo ♪
"And then wave!
And, Daddy, wave!"
[ Laughter ]
And he's got, like,
this really tough
kind of musical --
And he'd be like, "I got it!
I got it. Leave me alone."
You can't direct your parents.
-No, no, no.
-You know, I know
Martin Scorsese put his mom in,
like, a lot of his movies.
-Yeah.
-And I don't know how he did it,
because I was just hearing --
Like, around -- after take five,
my dad was like,
"How many more?"
[ Laughter ]
"'Cause I have a real job."
-Also, Stephen Sondheim
was a very important person
in Jonathan's life.
-Yes.
-And Bradley Whitford plays him.
I imagine that's something
you don't take on lightly,
to play Stephen Sondheim.
-No. You -- You made it
very difficult for me,
because in the great
"Co-Op: The Musical" --
I don't know if you've seen
"Co-Op: The Musical."
"Documentary Now" --
it's a popular show.
Dozens of fans in the audience!
-Dozens of fans.
-John Mulaney plays Sondheim.
-Yeah, Mulaney did
a very good Sondheim.
-He did a brilliant Sondheim.
-Yeah.
-So, you know, we --
Luckily, we were in a different
age bracket of Sondheim,
so we cast Bradley as Sondheim.
-And Sondheim liked it, right?
He liked the performance?
-Yes, he -- he wrote me,
"You treated me gently
and royally,
for which I am grateful."
But he had a note,
which is there's --
there's a moment in which
the character of Sondheim
leaves a message for --
for Jonathan Larson,
and I forget
what the sentence was,
but he was like,
"I would never say that."
[ Laughter ]
"Can I rewrite
my voicemail message?"
-So he thought the way
you presented him in the film,
even though it was him
being kind,
was maybe a little cliché?
-Yeah, this one moment,
this one sentence.
-Yeah.
-He was like, "I think you have
a bright future
in this business."
And he was like,
"I would never say
'bright future
in this business.'"
And so he said,
"Can you rewrite it?
And if you can't get the actor
back to record the voicemail,
I'll -- I'll --
I'll record myself."
And I was like,
"I can't get him."
[ Laughter ]
"I'm sorry.
Would you please?"
And so, he -- so we have, like,
a rewrite from Sondheim
in our movie,
and it's his voice
on the voicemail
to Jonathan Larson.
-Just this cosmic
reaching across the years.
-Now that's a pretty good cameo.
You know,
with all respect to Luis.
[ Applause ]
-Yeah, it's --
that's how you do allegro.
-That's how you do it.
Hey, thank you so much
for being here.
-Thank you for having me back.
-Congrats on both films.
You guys,
that's Lin-Manuel Miranda.
"Tick, Tick...Boom!"
available on Netflix.
"Encanto" in theaters
everywhere tomorrow.